[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
i spit on myself happy sometime in
november you freaks
what a show we've got for you mike rowe
is here in the house
he's the first guest we had a hose down
before the show
he's done some of the dirtiest jobs on
the planet but he says being cat's
housekeeper was by far the worst
ah cat she vapes jewel pods to keep from
eating tide pods
and of course there's kellyanne conway
she is the reason jim acosta became a
bedwetter
we'll get to tyrus later
so last saturday i did a live show in
birmingham alabama it was a great time
had by all especially me whoever sent
the three little people strippers to my
trailer after the show was greatly
appreciated
it's amazing what they can get up to
when you stack them like a sleeve of
ritz crackers
but that's the thing about doing these
live shows people give me things and not
just cold sores they give they give me
stuffed unicorns home baked brownies a
sketch of me half naked lying on a
bare-skinned rug
and that came from pete hegseth
i remember posing for that sketch he and
the role of jack and me as rose and
titanic
i should stop but my point is i get a
lot of stuff handed to me and it's
impossible to look at everything usually
i leave some things behind except the
ones i can smuggle onto the plane then
gently remove in the bathroom
but saturday a gentleman handed me an
envelope stuffed with paper it's
something i would normally have someone
else open the last thing i need is
another marriage proposal from some
stranger you remember this guy
huh
what happened to him he came and went
like a jets head coach
i know i don't even know what that means
but guys remember if you're going to
propose you got to put a ring on it and
i don't mean my finger
i don't know what i mean sorry kellyanne
but since i already had a fifth of gin i
decided to open the envelope and lo and
behold it wasn't a death threat or some
mysterious white powder sorry about that
cat
it was a letter from jim burns formerly
in charge of solution architecture of
microsoft essentially his job was to
come up with solutions for problems it's
a weird job because once you come up
with a solution you're out of a job it's
why democrats will work forever
but he sent me he sent me an idea that
smacked me in the face harder than moe
hitting curly
it's called the mlk dream score which
would grade political candidates based
on their adherence to martin luther
king's i have a dream speech now how
simple is this it's as simple as eric
swalwell
he's simple and it would be easier to
implement than my shoe lifts but it
tackles the gulf between people who
claim they have your best interests at
heart but then screw you over like a
weatherman
it describes every left-wing leader in
the last two decades as burns points out
there is no quick and accurate way to
assess a candidate's suitability for
blacks because they've been hoodwinked
into voting for democrats who spout
principles that sound good but then
enact policies completely contrary to
mlk's vision it's politics in a
left-wing nutshell
people weigh the eloquence of speeches
much more heavily than their actions
this is why obama was so popular he
nailed it on charisma but his policies
did less for blacks than the casting
director for friends
can you think about one
you can't can you
aisha taylor tyler maybe but you can say
that about everyone from jesse jackson
to the squad compare that to trump who
to be honest his deliberately wasn't
always great at times but even when
trump was as eloquent as rasputin
without the sex appeal
his policies were more helpful to blacks
than any modern era president in one
breath he might call the nfl dealers
sons of [ __ ] but in the next create
the lowest unemployment for blacks in
modern history you see it goes back to
words versus deeds trump always nailed
the deeds but he gave fodder to his
critics with the words it was harder for
for him to resist media bait than brian
stelter is with a twinkie casserole
the mlk dream score solves this problem
by scoring candidates using the
principles embodied in the mlk speech
and it's easy you create a website
mlkdreamscore.com which exists which has
the actual speech and then a scorecard
with a selectable map of the country you
can visit your state find your candidate
in their dream score it's like a fantasy
football league for politicians if it's
high it would show a happy mlk if it's
low it would be angry and all candidates
would be treated the same regardless of
race in other words they would be judged
on the content of their policies not the
color of their skin
sure charisma might count for something
but not a lot after all this is about
finding a great leader not the next
american idol so obama would get a low
score because although he was cool his
policies left blacks cold biden would
get scored zero for excusing physical
violence and protests creating
polarization by branding people as
racist and having no interest in a quote
beautiful symphony of brotherhood
but winsome sears would kick ass because
her words are consistent with mlk's
speech about principles and character
deeds are weighted versus words and it's
a great way to gauge a leader it would
literally get rid of every liberal mayor
in days if not seconds i wonder what the
angry black male thinks
[Music]
all right fellas you guys are here to
pitch to me today about fixing racial
division in this country all right i'm
all ears what do you got yes and and
thanks for having us tyrus
don't do that
well here at white and white associates
we focus group anxious caucasians to
help people of color like you like me
and i know that sounds like i was saying
you people yeah because you did
i think they'll still like some of the
ideas we have
permanent daylight savings for black
people because we're always an hour late
this is nothing but stupid stereotypes
you clowns have anything else to do
today besides waste my time
what if someone had a dream go on
where people weren't judged by
stereotypes and race uh instead on the
content of their character
okay all right let me look at this list
again let me just
you know what i actually like this one
so uh this is the first time i've ever
done a monologue based on something a
fan gave me other than a fake phone
number
but it shows you where great ideas come
from they come from you when you sit
down and you think hard you will be
surprised what comes out of you
especially if you do your best thinking
on the toilet
[Applause]
always end
on a poop joke let's welcome tonight's
guest she grew up working on a berry
farm and tonight she's working with some
nuts former senior counselor since
president trump kellyanne conway
none of his dirty jobs prepared him for
tonight host of how america works on fox
nation mike rowe
she's like glitter bright fun and
impossible to get rid of boston's
contributor captain
and the world revolves around him
literally
my massive sidekick in the nwa world
television champions terrace
i apologize for ending that monologue on
a poop joke it's been a bone of
contention among everybody here that i'm
making too many poop jokes i'm trying to
cut them down i hope i did not offend
you it's hard to offend me i know i have
really thick shock absorbers i promise
yes yes what do you make of this idea
does it make sense it's very simple i
love it yeah i love it because that was
the message of martin luther king and
you're right about deeds versus words
like i worked in administration the
trump pence administration where
millions got off welfare millions got
all food stamps the lowest unemployment
rate for african americans asian
americans
uh is hispanic americans women were in
the workforce and you know as the kids
were forced out of school the women
their moms were forced out of the
workforce and we're still reckoning with
that to say nothing of all the wocus
joke woke us broke curricula out there
but i like it and it would i think that
you would give biden harris a big zero i
think what you described is exactly why
he's at 38 approval and she's at 28
because people said you didn't make good
on any promise you didn't unify the
country you don't care about bipartisan
action you don't care about people and
your policies are wrong-headed yeah but
thank god they got rid of those mean
tweets they got high
but those tweets are gone thank god mike
those tweets are driving me keeping me
up all night aside from thinking about
you
my
my delicious my delicious little blue
king king
it's the canadian tuxedo
oh that's not true they don't have
tuxedos thank you for the uh for the
poop joke right yeah i mean my entire
career season one of dirty jobs was
literally feces from every species yeah
that was
that's how the network slugged it and
that's all we did so it's it's nice to
be home people yeah they got to get over
it man they got to get over it it's part
of life feces from another speech it
sounds like a great restaurant but i'll
stop what do you make of this idea
because you you always have good ideas
about how to fix things no no i don't
actually the
great idea is that you're listening to
your fans and everything well we did 300
dirty jobs and i'd say 280 of them were
fan suggestions like so all the ideas
came in from that so that's really great
i love the dream score if we want to
color blind society i don't really know
what to say about policies that revolve
entirely around color how do you get
away from it at some point you know
there's the whole leveling of the
playing field thing i get it but
the man talked about a color blind
future right if we're ever going to get
there i got this thing called a uh
called a sweat pledge in my foundation
and people have to sign it it's kind of
an old throwback to the boy scouts but
it's 12 simple statements of belief
things like personal responsibility
delay gratification and so forth all the
horatio alger stuff right it has been
deemed recently uh as alt right of
course and the
questions that come now every year we've
given away maybe 1400 of these work
ethic scholarships but every year now
more and more how many women how many
people of color and because it's a
foundation and not a company i can say
quite candidly who cares yeah right i
mean i don't know that we're trying to
gauge for work ethic and
from what i've seen no gender or race
has a corner on that
and so hilarity ensues and things get
very sporty online and we have this
conversation but it always comes back to
this exact thing if you want a color
blind future what in the world are you
doing with the color obsessed present
there you go that's it that wasn't bad
your uh
your theory or his theory is brilliant
but it's problematic good word uh
because it goes against the entire
foundation of what the democratic party
has always been about because any time a
brother becomes successful in a free
thinker
they take our black cards away they
can't get mine good luck trying but they
love
to as soon as you become successful you
know what i make so much a year i'm
gonna i don't like this tax bracket i'm
gonna look at this this policy works for
me hey oh i'm a republican oh you're a
republican uh
your blackness is gone
and your new nickname is uncle tom yes
because you are you can't succeed under
their plan you need us we have to treat
you like children so and bait you and
tell you we're gonna do this and this
and then when you can't succeed it's not
their fault i mean you are black i mean
did you have a father
the answer was you know what i'm saying
but no you laugh but that they say that
with a straight face but don't worry
we're going to get you on welfare and uh
we'll get you some kind of other things
you can possibly do a vouchers you can
get on the bus
and you made it young man there you go
kat have you ever used anything from a
viewer or a fan well they're mostly
prison letters
and they don't even have pictures so i
can't even tell if they're hot prisoners
or not
years ago before you were married right
yes
right
also never before i was married not a
friend no never no they're in prison now
i got a little distracted during your
monologue though cause you mentioned
that happy and sad i'm okay i started
thinking of like what if we rated other
things like that i don't know like the
yelp or like those signs at the doctor
like rate your pain and it's a bunch of
you know different mlk faces but um
i'm just saying my brain went there
should i not be saying where my brain
goes has that been my problem for all
these years i don't know uh but look for
me i just think that for the government
in general i wanna whoever's gonna do
less right you know i don't like i don't
like the deeds as long as the deeds are
undoing other deeds those are my
favorite yes the deeds that subtract
other deeds there's too many rules yes
dirty deeds
under cheap ac dc there you go
no not black and black what's it from
which album first one wasn't it i think
it's the second it's i i don't know oh
you're trying to go with your theme i
know you are back in black you know
there you go can i say one quick thing
about the democratic party the big joke
is they had about two dozen democrats
running for president
they had uh
black man black woman hispanic american
samoan that was tulsi gabbard not right
elizabeth warren yes yes
they had the first openly gay candidate
they had a male socialist a female
social they really had one of everything
you know who they ended up with yes
oh i know
please the old white guy thank you
that is the democratic party in a
nutshell yeah they had one openly gay
man and they had uh mayor pete
all right
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else